[موسيقى]
ما في كتير دراسات صراحه عن مشاكل الغده
الدرقيه اثناء شهر الصيام لكن راح ضوي على
بعض النقاط المهمه الناس اللي بياخذوا
الهرمون الدرقي الناس اللي عندهم يعني
قصور في الدقه الوقت المناسب لاخذ هذا
الهرمون عاده هو قبل الذهاب الى فراش من
النوم على الاقل لازم يكون في عندي ساعتين
بدون اكل قبل الذهاب الى النوم لانه هذا
هو الوقت المناسب لامتصاص هذا الهرمون
وظائف الغده الدرقيه قد يحدث عليها بعض
الاضطرابات اذا سوينا فحص دم
بين الشهرين ثلاث شهور بعض الصيام وهذا
طبيعي جدا فممكن احنا نعيد التحليل بعد
فتره وما نحكم على التحليل خلال شهرين او
ثلاثه اشهر بعض الصيام الناس اللي عندهم
فرط في نشاط في الغده الدرقيه او نسميها
اذا كان في هناك فرض نشاط الدرق الشديد
فقد يكون صعب جدا لا يكون في جوع شديد
وهذا موضوع يجب الانتباه له اما اذا كان
في عندي فرق نشاط مسيطر عليه بالدواء او
خفيف واخف الادويه ممكن انه يصير باي وقت
خلال النهار ما في اي وقت معين لاخر
الدوام
[موسيقى]